in both of these moments the Lord
achieves his recognition through another
consciousness for in them that other
consciousness is expressively something
uh nacelle both by its working out of
the thing and by its dependence on a
specific existence in neither case can
it be lord over the being of the thing
and apps achieve absolute negation of it
here therefore is present this moment of
recognition that is that the other
consciousness sets aside its own being
for self and in so doing itself
does what the first does to it similarly
the other moment too is present that
this action of the second is the first
own action for what the bondsmen does is
really the action of the Lord the
latter's essential nature is to exist
only for himself he is a sheer negative
power for whom the thing is nothing thus
he is the pure honest the pure essential
action in this relationship while the
action of the bondsman is impure and
unofficial but for recognition proper
the moment is lacking that what the Lord
does to the other he also does to
himself and what the bondsman does to
himself he should also do to the other
the outcome is a recognition that is
one-sided and unequal
the absolutely key issue that's arising
in paragraph 191 event moving through
the other paragraphs it is this question
of recognition is the master getting
what he or she most truly desires which
it is not just enjoyment of the world of
objects not just to get to boss somebody
around but to have this recognition that
we saw is at the the core of
self-consciousness and at the bottom of
our desires at least for Hegel so the
question has to be put by working
through what the relationship of the
Lord the master the slave and the thing
actually turned out to be at first it
looks like the the master is getting
everything that he or she wants this is
perfect he's in the top dog position he
gets to tell the slave what to do he
even gets to decide what thing the slave
is gonna work on how long the slave is
gonna work what constitutes good
performance bad performance gets to
punish the slave that the slave doesn't
do but what he wants gets to you know
rewarded the slave if he or she decides
that is that the slave is worth it so it
sounds pretty good
for the master but we're already gonna
see the beginnings of the shift that's
taking place that's underlying this
entire dialectic he says in both these
moments the Lord achieves his
recognitions for another consciousness
right both of these moments refers back
to the last paragraph so in them that
other consciousness he says is
expressively something on essential the
slave is less than a person the slave is
a person that you can make do your
bidding that you can bend to your will
why both my it's working on the thing
the slave is in a subordinate position
by being made as a human being to engage
with the nine
human world that requires labor that
requires some cultivation in order to
make it accessible to our desires as
human beings and by its dependence on a
specific existence the slave remember
was the one who gave in and said slavery
is better than dying I'd rather serve
than you know risk complete annihilation
there are specific existence is what
they valued most and as we saw there's a
paradox there because they don't get to
enjoy their specific existence instead
they're forced to expend their life
their labor doing this work for the
master so he says in neither case can
the servant be the Lord over the being
of the thing and if she an absolute
negation we just saw this already the
servant is not allowed to enjoy the
thing the way that the master is the
master is the one who gets the cream of
the crop the master is the one who gets
the first fruits unless they want to
give it to another master as was often
done in religious rituals right first
fruits so he says here therefore is
present this moment of recognition and
what's the moment of recognition well
there's two aspects to it this goes back
to the discussions that we saw earlier
on in this section about the way in
which self-consciousness is engage with
each other
what is the recognition that they're
actually looking for there is you might
say a sort of interpenetration of the
two self-consciousness they end up
having a reciprocal relation where as
Hegel says what one does to oneself is
what the other is doing to one and what
one is doing to the other is what one is
doing to oneself so there's what seems
to be an equal playing field as we call
it it kind of equalization or a
levelling of things but we don't have
that in the master and slave instead
it's actually as Hegel says one sided
right
whenever things are one-sided that's
always a sign just like whenever you see
the word immediate look out because
something is conveying to them becoming
up that's gonna require us to go beyond
that so how is the slave the slave is
doing the work of recognition the master
does not now what makes us really
interesting is that the master can't
really get recognition if the master is
not willing to do some of the work him
or herself we'll see how that that comes
about so he says here's here's present
this moment of recognition the other
consciousness sets aside its own being
herself
like I said slave once it's placed in
this dependent condition doesn't get to
decide for itself what it's going to be
you know if the slave is supposed to be
blowing glass the slave doesn't get to
say you know I think I'd much rather be
a musician the master then comes along
and says knock it off you're blowing
glass the slave does not get to set his
or her own hours does not get to
determine the conditions under which he
or she lives they lack freedom in other
words they lack the real freedom that
comes with determining what kind of
existence what kind of beating for self
what kind of self identity what is going
to help even being able to experiment
with this or being able to pose it as a
project sometimes the slaves might say
you know I don't think that I should be
breaking rocks all day to make gravel
for these roads in some cases the master
will say all right you're getting
punished just for even bringing that up
that's how you know extensive the the
estrangement the alienation of the slave
is going to be so Lenny says the the
other consciousness sets aside its own
being for self and in doing so does what
the first does to it this is important
why does the slave if you have to set
aside its own being for self because
the master requires them because the
master commands them because the master
determines that for the slip
so he says similarly the other moment -
as present the action of the second is
the first action so here we have what is
the action of the slave the action is
work work upon the thing and it appears
to be something that the slave can at
least say well this is my own action
right but it's really the lord's action
the Lord is more fundamental the master
the master is the one who says you're
going to go out there in the farm those
fields where you're gonna start sweeping
this dirty room and if you if you want
to give me any guff you're not going to
like what happens in her words the slave
buying him or herself is not choosing to
work upon the thing to transform the
thing into an object of desire and an
object of enjoyment for the master so
it's really the lord's action that's
taking place within the slave so it says
the latter is the central nature the
Lord so here we didn't have a couple of
things that Hegel tells us about the
master war his essential nature's to
exist only for himself nobody else
except perhaps another master gets to
tell the master what to do
slaves certainly don't get to tell the
master what to do they just get to say
well you know if you want the job done
this way I think I need a new broom or
you're probably going to need to buy
some more cooking oil if you want this
stuff cooked or we're gonna need some
vinegar if you want this this crop
preserved in glass jars for yourself the
master doesn't suck he's not subject to
anything like that he doesn't suffer any
of those sorts of constraints he exists
only for himself as Hegel says he is he
says the sheer negative power for whom
the thing is nothing we've already seen
this another way of talking about that
is the master is freedom absolute
freedom at least at this stage the
master can decide what to do with the
thing
the master could say let's burn down the
fields or you know this house is too
messy let's just destroy it
the master probably won't do that but
that's within their purview the slave
imagine as the slave says I don't want
to farm these fields let me just burn
them up you know that's not going to fly
in this sort of arrangement does it the
master however does you have the
capacity to negate whatever they want
they have the freedom to make things
otherwise and any freedom it seems that
the slave has to make things otherwise
through their work is coming through the
initiative of the master so the master
determines what the work is and in this
process is receiving a one-sided
recognition from the slave in what the
slave is doing with the object with the
thing with the the locus of work the
locus of activity so he says the action
of the bondsman is impure and an
essential and think for a moment the way
that we even today and again I don't
want to say we want to generalize too
much not saying that managerial
relationships are relationships of
master and slave but there is something
analogous going on here when the boss
takes the credit for the work that the
workers do for what they accomplish
because the boss is the one who gets to
write the report the one who gets to
give the narrative of what actually took
place to appropriate the the transformed
objects of labour that the workers do we
have something like what Hegel is
describing here the action of the
bondsman is considered impure in
essential it's not really that important
again I brought up Aristotle a number of
points your Aristotle it establishes a
kind of hierarchy the one who's calling
the shots the one who is engaging in
determining things with that Greek word
arcing that I've brought up a couple
times
I should write that down here you know
if we want to use this in terms of Greek
terms arcing to rule to dominate to be
in charge the person who's in charge
their reaction is seen as being
essential as the action that puts other
action into process that guides that the
orient set that sets as I've said the
agenda the work of the slave the labor
the activity is seen as being in
essential as being in a certain respect
almost less than a human as being
brutish as being random so can you
actually get recognition out of this
Hegel says for recognition proper the
moment is lacking that what the Lord
does to the other he also does to
himself the Lord does not treat himself
as a servant now it could be that you
could have Lords who you know have great
self-discipline and do treat themselves
that way but that's not what he's
talking about at this point the Lord
ought to do to the other what he does to
himself and what the bondsman does to
himself he should also do to the other
the master is not allowing the slave to
do that that we're a warder or you know
bonds but if he is you like that what
the what the slave is doing it is really
coming from the master and not the other
way around
so he says the outcome is a recognition
that is one-sided and unequal and the
question that is is that sort of
recognition what it is that the master
really had a desire for
in this recognition the UH nacelle
consciousness is for the Lord the object
which constitutes the truth of his
certainty of himself but it is clear
that this object does not correspond to
its notion but rather that the object in
which the Lord has achieved his lordship
has in reality turned out to be
something quite different from an
independent consciousness what now
really confronts him is not an
independent consciousness but it
dependent one he is therefore not
certain of being for self as the truth
of himself on the contrary his truth is
in reality the unofficial consciousness
and it's unofficial action
now in paragraph 192 we're starting to
see the importance and the initiative
shift from the side of the master to
that of the slave it's not going to
occur as such in this paragraph but it
will happen in the next paragraph but
here Hegel is setting it up remember the
worry that we saw at the laughs at the
end of the last paragraph number 191 now
in number one 92 he says in this
recognition the unofficial consciousness
the servant the slave is for the Lord
the object which constitutes the truth
in a certainty of himself and that is
what the Lord has been seeking that is
what the master has been looking what
every self consciousness actually
desires is to have a self certainty that
is also a true self certainly one that
is recognized by another and freely
recognized reciprocally recognized by
another so what the Lord is really
desiring in some other independent
self-consciousness as their object with
which they can have a or with whom
rather they can have a reciprocal
relation a full recognition which gives
them the truth of their self certainty
not only in this direction but also the
master would be giving it in this
direction you might say well can't the
class of masters do that for themselves
Hinkel doesn't really consider that as a
possibility at this point and we'll see
why that can't be the case in in just a
little bit so this doesn't happen
instead the object of the Masters desire
what is it that he or she is really
seeking it is the slave and the
relationship is one of ruling of setting
them to work and so we have this whole
complex of the slave working upon the
thing this is not going to provide the
kind of wreck
mission that the master wants like he
says it's clear this object does not
correspond to its notion was its notion
another independent self-consciousness
behind the sheer fact of subjugating and
ruling dominating the slave making the
slave be in effect a means to an end a
tool for one's own desires one places
the slave into a condition that slave is
not going to be particularly happy about
to begin with right but also that can't
give the master what it is that he or
she really desires out of the
relationship that is an equal relation
when you subjugate somebody you are
placing them below yourself you are
treating them as less than you and
therefore you can't also treat them and
expect them to treat you as an equal in
return I mean you can you can this is
something worth thinking about you can
create all sorts of double bindings for
your slaves right you can say be
spontaneous just tell me what's on your
mind
you know don't treat me like a master
just treat me like I'm just one of your
fellow slaves and that might work for a
little bit but as soon as the slave
starts to really exercise the freedom
that seems to be involved in that the
master will then say oh I really that
wasn't what I expected from you I don't
really want that but without that risk
without that openness you can't get real
recognition like the master wants to get
so he says it's that the object which
the Lord has achieved as lordship has in
reality - turned out to be something
quite different from an independent
consciousness it's a dependent
consciousness the Lord is the one who
the the dependent consciousness depends
upon for it's it's you know purpose for
its meaning for its activity and so he
says he is therefore not certain of
beating herself out of the truth
of himself so the Lord doesn't get this
truth of such certainty truth and sell
certain together instead they do here
self certainty they are the one who gets
to feel like they are in charge like
they know who they are but there's
always going to be some some lacunae
some some gaps some shadows some doubts
and the truth is going to lie on the
side of the servants this is an
incredibly important transformative
moment in the dialectic the truth of the
master doesn't reside in the master or
in his or her mastery of the slave
instead the truth is found over here in
the world of independent objects and in
the activity of the slave upon those
independent objects so there's a kind of
sundering you can't have them further
apart from each other you might say it's
just fortunate that I happen to picked
up the chalkboard that way so they says
because truth is in reality the UH
nacelles the truth of the master is the
slave and the activity of the slave and
the world that the slave engages so the
master doesn't possess his or her own
truth because of being a master and
ruling out this other relationship it
also lies in the unofficial
consciousnesses on essential action this
is very revolutionary this is a
fundamentally transformative moment
the truth of the independent
consciousness is accordingly the servile
consciousness of the bondman this it is
true appears at first outside of itself
and not as the truth of
self-consciousness
but just as lordship showed that it's
essential nature is the reverse of what
it wants to be
so to servitude in its consummation will
really turn into an opposite of what it
immediately is as a consciousness forced
back into itself it will withdraw into
itself and be transformed into a truly
independent consciousness
in paragraphs 191 and 192 Hagel was
setting us up for a pivotal shift and
this is now going to happen in paragraph
193 but as usual it's not going to
happen all at once we're going to see
the very first beginnings of it but this
is a transitional point he says the
truth of the independence of
consciousness is accordingly the
survival the working the servant
self-consciousness or consciousness of
the bonds of the slave so the truth that
the the master was seeking to hear is
something that they really want at the
foundation of truth of their self
consciousness does not reside in them it
does not reside and the power that they
hold it does not reside in their action
of ruling of determining of
appropriating of enjoying all those
things are going to turn out to be as
Hegel's can say less essential than
what's happening over here on the part
of the dependent consciousness the slave
the truth lies on the part of the slave
and the slave is not yet conscious of
that that's going to require some
further dialectical work so he says this
is it is true appears at first outside
of itself and not as the truth of self
consciousness see if the slave has to
realize him or herself as indeed self
consciousness and not just as dependent
self consciousness the master has been
self-consciousness and sort of stressing
the aspect of the independence which
both self consciousness was originally
possessed weren't able to fully
actualize you know now the master is
really able to be independent because
they've got somebody else doing all of
the dirty work for them and the slave
feels like he or she is not really a
full person they have to work they have
to work on this world of objects but
that were
is where the truth of self-consciousness
at least at this stage of the dialectic
is going to reside so the truth gets
externalized it gets placed outside of
self-consciousness he says but just as
lordship showed that it's essential
essential nature is the reverse of what
it wants to be the Lord of the sort of
the master doesn't really get the
recognition that he or she desired even
though they do have rule even though
they do have power even though they have
a kind of actuality and a recognition
socially that the servant doesn't have
they're not getting the recognition the
interpersonal recognition the deep down
desire that they have just as this this
reversal took place so to servitude in
its consummation he says will really
turn into the opposite of what it
immediately is we look at a servant and
he say look at that poor bastard he's
stopped working and he can't really
imagine anything better
you know he'll never get out of that
position but he will Hegel is going to
churn out the process by which this
reversal will occur so he says as a
consciousness forced back into itself it
will withdraw into itself and be
transformed into a truly independent
consciousness how's that can happen by
grasping that truth that is externalized
the truth of self-consciousness
externalized to itself in work in the
thing and its relationship to that
that's what follows in the rest of this
section
you